you know that visualpolitik is one of
the few political channels that pays a
lot of attention to latin america one of
the least covered regions
in the world perhaps that is why many of
you have often asked us
to talk more about latin america despite
the way i butcher spanish names
well we have a solution
[Music]
we're proud to present latam politik a
newsletter that we have prepared
together with geopolitical consulting
firm
perch perspectives if you subscribe
every month you will receive 12
newsletters with the best
information and analysis on latin
america to keep you up to date and
better understand
everything that is happening in the
region the cost you can subscribe for
less than 35 cents per newsletter less
than a small taco or donut a week
in return you'll be kept up to date on
all the major happenings in the region
and better understand all the possible
implications
in addition all of you who support us at
patreon level 4
and 5 will receive latin politic at zero
cost
you can find all the info at
latimepolitik.com
[Applause]
[Music]
sometimes it happens that the most
unsuspected people end up making a
splash
and become the surprise protagonists on
the world stage you see my friends this
may be what best summarizes lenin
moreno's path
to the presidency of ecuador
[Music]
we are talking about a man who for more
than six years was vice president to
rafael correa himself one of the great
leaders of the so-called 21st century
socialism we are talking about a
politician who came to the corondelet
palace
ecuador's equivalent of the white house
amidst accusations of fraud to keep
carrera's movement careerism
standing against all odds but who
shortly thereafter completely disavowed
the legacy of his predecessor a legacy
that
as it turns out made moreno's presidency
quite a bumpy right
you see by the end of carrera's
presidency ecuador was in a very
delicate situation once the more than 80
billion dollars of income generated by
the oil price boom had been consumed the
ecuadorian economy entered into a huge
spiral of crisis budgetary imbalances
and public debt
we owe almost 75 billion dollars
we have to pay 10 plus capital of that
amount almost 11 billion dollars
annually in debt service
lenin moreno of course macroeconomic
imbalances were not the only thing lenny
moreno encountered when he became
president
but now his time has passed four years
after coming to power
ecuador is sliding into a new era under
a new presidency and the question we are
pondering is
what is ecuador's future what kind of
ecuador will lenin mourinho leave to his
successor would you like to know how
this president has spent his time in the
coronal a palace
i bet you do so let's get cracking
the rapture
mourinho's presidency began with a very
clear idea in mind ecuador was in very
bad shape economically and a lot of
money was needed
and to achieve this there was really no
other way than for the country to
disassociate itself from the growing
block of latin american 21st century
socialism and thus demonstrate that the
new ecuadorian government was nothing
like carreras nor like that venezuela
bolivia or kirchner's argentina
i am not interested in power i am
interested in the welfare of all
i am interested in the present and
future of ecuador i'm interested in the
country in which our children and
grandchildren will
live the future of our elders lenin
moreno president of ecuador
however after more than 10 years of
rafael carrera's government this was not
going to be an easy task
for example among the main stumbling
blocks was the enormous distrust of
international investors towards a
country that in 2008 had announced a
debt default a default that was not
caused by any particular economic or
financial problem at the time
but was purely and simply due to a
political and ideological issue
overnight
international investors were confronted
with news like this
december 12 2008 ecuador says it will
default on its foreign debt wall street
journal
and obviously if you do not pay your
debts you cannot expect to borrow again
and if you do it's more than likely that
you'll have to pay very high interest
rates
and that is exactly what happened so
that when the price of oil began to
collapse in 2014 the ecuadorian economy
gradually followed suit
thus lenin moreno found himself at the
helm of an ecuador
riddled with problems and where public
revenues were simply not enough to pay
the bills so at that point the decision
taken by the new president was to wipe
the slate clean
so to speak so that shortly after coming
to power he began to break off all
relations
with his predecessor a break with his
mentor that he wanted to stage
in style
among lenin moreno's first decision was
to remove ecuador from una
sur the economic block of countries
formed at the san paulo forum
then to remove ecuador from alba the
bolivian alliance for the peoples of our
america created by hugo chavez himself
to recognize juan guido as the
illegitimate president of venezuela to
end julian assange's asylum in the
ecuadorian embassy in london
and re-establish a good bilateral
relationship with the united states a
process that
by the way culminated in an unexpected
meeting between the ecuadorian president
and donald trump
in february 2020. mourinho also
dismissed his vice president jorge glass
just
two months after taking office glass had
also been vice president under rafael
carrera and was accused of receiving
13.5 million us dollars
in bribes from the infamous brazilian
construction company oberek
in other words as you can see lenin
moreno practically made a total break
with a legacy of carrera
[Music]
and while it is true that none of those
initial actions consisted of actual
economic reforms
they did send the message that he was
not carrera something that for example
may have helped the country to regain
access to multi-million dollar loans on
reasonable terms from international
organizations such as the imf and the
world bank
february 21st 2019 ecuador announces
international loans for 10
billion dollars finances.com of course
as you can imagine the money had a
specific purpose to support what is
known as the ecuadorian government's
prosperity plan a reform plan that meant
dismantling piece by piece a good part
of carrera's legacy including many of
the existing subsidies which as we will
see
would mark the second half of his
presidency but having said that and now
we know how and why he broke with his
predecessor the big question for us
the question i'm sure many of you are
asking yourselves at this very moment is
is ecuador a better country today than
it was four years ago
to answer that let's take a look
one government two stages
the presidency of lenin moreno in
ecuador can be divided into two
well-defined periods the first between
2017 to 2019 and the second period
between 2019 and 2021. the first of
these two phases was characterized as
we've already told you by an abrupt and
total break with careerism and by the
attempt to carry out economic reforms
aimed at regaining the confidence of the
markets in fact
shortly after coming to power in
september 2017 moreno announced his
first major plan
for the country his economic programme
for the next four years
program included among other things an
increase in income tax for corporations
from 22 to 25
with some exceptions for small companies
the elimination of the capital gains law
in an attempt to boost construction and
the increase of tariffs on 375 goods as
a protectionist measure as far as
austerity goes the goal of reducing the
deficit to 1
by 2020 was set with measures such as a
10 reduction in the salaries of
high-ranking several severance and
a freeze on hiring in the public sector
among others
in other words we are talking about a
plan that could well fit into a
framework of moderate center-left
policies with the understanding that
unlimited debt
is never a good idea this first period
was also marked by the fight against
corruption
let's not fool ourselves in addition to
being relatively popular it is also
important when it comes to doing
business the cleaner a country is and
the more it appears to be so
the better nobody wants to leave their
money in the hands of crooks
well the fact is that in order to carry
out this battle moreno made use of two
major tools on the one hand the
constitutional referendum and the
popular consultation held in february
and an anti-corruption law approved in
december 2020. with the first mourinho
pushed for a change so the country's
very constitution would prohibit people
convicted of corruption offences from
running for
office in addition this consultation
also approved things such as the limit
of one re-election for all elected
authorities
and the repeal of the capital gains law
itself secondly the 2020 anti-corruption
law seeks to impose new controls on
public contracting and private sector
corruption a law which although moreno
denies it most likely was one of the imf
demands in exchange for lending ecuador
another two billion dollars and well
at the end of the day what can i say if
you want my money i'd say that the first
thing
i'd have to do is make sure that i put
it in good hands don't you think
it really makes sense however whether or
not all these measures will translate
into real results
is something that only time will tell to
begin with the constitutional change
prevented raphael carrera convicted of
corruption from trying to return to
power at least
not directly but this is not the end of
the story during moreno's presidency
steps have also been taken in other
areas such as freedom of the press
mourinho promised during his election
campaign to modify the 2013
organic law of communication a law
passed by ex-president carrera who
determined that communication was a
public service and gave the government
the authority to regulate the content of
the media
and to investigate and sanction
journalists and lenin fulfilled this
promise
the national assembly approved a
modification in 2018 that came into
force the following year
and that among other things eliminated
the department known as supercom the
superintendence of information and
communication the media sanctioning body
that rafael carrera's government
like so much
[Music]
well this first period in which as you
can see it seems fair to say there were
many advances came to an
end in 2019 and the question is what
happened at that time for us to talk
about a change of period
well buckle up because here right here
is where the curveballs start rolling in
check this out
the decree the turning point
so as you have seen lenin moreno's
presidency started with everyone
thinking that we would see a reboot of
carrera's policies and instead it ended
up being a kind of unexpected
transition you know a betrayal for some
and an insufficient change for others
as a result credibility in president
moreno's word fell from 67
in august 2017 to a low of 10.4 on
october 2019 when mourinho also
announced the famous
decree 883. this decree that eliminated
fuel subsidies
marked the beginning of his plummeting
popularity
the ecuadorian president presented this
measure as one of the tools needed to
reduce the deficit
and thus be able to control the increase
in public debt
but the issue of fuel subsidies in
ecuador is not a trivial matter ecuador
has been subsidising fuels since long
before rafael carrera in fact for more
than 40 years
since way back in 1974 however 11 days
after the start of the violent protest
that arose over the attempt to eliminate
the fuel subsidy mourinho decided to
backtrack and
repeal the controversial decree 883
of course getting rid of subsidies that
have been in place for decades no matter
how inefficient and adequate they may be
is an almost impossible task especially
if you want to do it without angering
a large part of the population to give
you an idea eliminating these subsidies
caused diesel prices to
double and regular gasoline prices to
increase by more than 25
so you can only imagine the enormous
anger of many ecuadorians
however hold on a moment because in
spite of this ecuador still had the
cheapest gasoline in all of latin
america
and let's not fool ourselves maintaining
this subsidy came at a very high price
fuel subsidies in ecuador accounts for
some 3.5 billion us dollars in spending
each year which is just over three
percent of gdp
and more than 20 of all oil export
revenues and to top it off this type of
formula encourages a much higher
consumption of oil which also increases
the cost of these public policies in
other words eliminating these subsidies
was one of the star measures to balance
the public accounts
so as you can imagine the repeal of
decree 883
completely destroyed the deficit
reduction forecasts the government had
been working with
and to add insult to injury the damage
had already been done
despite not achieving his goal the
political cost was inevitable for some
for approving it and for others for
repealing it the fact is that mourinho's
popularity plummeted from 77
at the beginning of his presidency to
less than 10 percent and no
since then he's not made up any ground
mourinho had his hashtag bring back
simon moment however in spite of
everything the government continued to
move forward along the same lines
september 24th 2020 the government
allows fuel imports for the private
sector
petro ecuador loses its monopoly on the
purchase and sale of derivatives for the
industrial sector
el commercial the emergence of the
coronavirus favors the deregulation
of the price of gasoline in ecuador the
government will apply
from july a system of price bands with a
ceiling and floor if the fuel fluctuates
below
the gas stations will charge that
minimum to the consumer and the excess
amount will go to the public coffers
the international price rises beyond
five percent
from one month to another then state
subsidies will be activated so that
citizens do not
feel the increase in price and yes it
can be said that this is strictly a
price deregulation since the government
still imposes a maximum price a minimum
price and
still contemplates subsidies
nevertheless it represents an amount of
savings for the public coffers that some
sources have put at around 1 billion us
dollars a year
as you can see mourinho inherited a
difficult economic situation once the
oil bonanza was over he had to play
the worst cards and to make matters
worse the coronavirus arrived
if economic growth in 2019 before the
coronavirus was already at a dismal 0.1
percent the ecuadorian gdp contracted by
in 2020 and forecasts indicate that it
will not return to solid growth levels
until at least 2024. the first
consequence of this has been an increase
in poverty levels to over 30 percent
of the population in addition the
drastic drop in oil revenues ecuador's
main source of foreign exchange has
meant that despite all the reforms the
government has been forced to continue
feeding the enormous debt
already dragging down the ecuadorian
economy
so you see my friends in spite of the
turnaround that lenin moreno tried to
make the truth is that luck has not been
on his side and now for the coming years
the next government faces a very
polarized society a country
increasingly dependent on international
creditors and a huge lack of economic
visibility where
is ecuador headed in short only time
will tell and now
it's over to you how do you evaluate the
reformist attempts of mourinho's term in
office
do you think they were enough or that on
the contrary they fell short how do you
think he should have dealt with the
protests of late 2019.
leave your answer in the comments below
and if you found this video interesting
don't forget to give us a thumbs up
and subscribe to visualpolitik best
regards and see you next time if you
want to learn more about politics and
world
affairs and hear some more of my lovely
voice come check out the reconsider
podcast where we don't
do the thinking for you find reconsider
at www.reconsidermedia.com or on apple
or google play or your favorite
podcatcher
[Music]